تنفيذ خطه اصلاح القضاء سيضع حكومه
نتنياهو خاصه امام عدد من التحديات
الداخليه وخارجيه فداخليا ردت القوه
المعارضه للخطه بمظاهرات كل يوم سبت
يتراوح عدد المشاركين فيها بين 80 الفا
ومئه وخمسين الفا وهي ارقام تؤكد ان حكومه
نتنياهو لا تمتلك افضليه جماهيريه حقيقيه
بعد ان وصلت الى الحكم بفارق 30 الف صوت
فقط خلال الانتخابات الاخيره كما ان
استطلاعات الراي تشير لتاييد الراي العام
قرار المحكمه العليا
65% من المستطلعين عارضوا تعيين درعي حتى
كتله المياه
43% منها قالوا انه ليس من المناسبه تولي
درعي منصب وزير اتهامات اخرى سيواجهها
نتنياهو منها شخصا الخطه بدافع الانتقام
والتحصين قبل التحقيقات معه فساد وخيانه
الامانه كان نتنياهو بنفسه من ابرز
المعارضين لاي محاولات تغييرا في السلطه
القضائيه ما الاتهام الثاني فهو استغلال
السلطه فبعد 14 شهرا بعيدا عن رئاسه
الحكومه اعدن تنياهو ترتيب اوراقه ليعود
عبره احزاب صهيونيه الصهيونيه الدينيه
وهذه الاحزاب تعادي المحكمه العليا لان
الاخيره مررت تشريعات تعتبرها الاحزاب
الدينيه مخالفه للشريعه اليهوديه كما رفضت
اعطاء الشرعيه لمئات البؤر الاستيطانيه
خارجيا سيكون نتنياهو في حرج امام واشنطن
التي لطالما تباهت بان اسرائيل هي الاكثر
ديمقراطيه في الشرق الاوسط حقيقه حقيقه
يدركها نتنياهو لذا حرص على التاكيد على
ان اي اصلاحات من القضاء ستتم عبر توافق
مع المعارضه
فيما يحاولون نتنياهو ايجاد طريقه
للالتفاف على قرار المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه واعاده زعيم شاسيه درعي الى
صفوف الحكومه تحول الحركه اثاره البعد
العرقي فاعتبرت ان سبب شطب عضويه درعي في
الحكومه هو العنصريه ضد اليهود الشرقيين
والحركه التي تشكلت احتجاجا على تلك
العنصريه مستغلين ان السواد الاعظم من
القضاه كانوا من اليهود الغربيين رغم ان
معظم الاسرائيليين يؤيدون القرار ضد درع
بسبب تكرار ادانته بالفساد فقد كان امضى
محكوميه بالسجن الفعلي بسبب قضيه اختلاس
ومن ابرز من ادين وسجن من اليهود الغربيين
ذوي الاصول الاوروبيه وزير الماليه السابق
عام 2009 ورئيس الوزراء
السابق عام 2014
من القدس العربيه